سنتحدث الان عن الهزات الارتداديه اتجاه
تصاعدي تتخذه هذه الهزات الارتداديه التي
اعاقبت زلزال سوريا وتركيا عددا وقوه اكثر
من 6000 واربعين هزه ارتداديه وصلت قوه
احداها لسته فاصل اربعه درجه اي بمثابه
زلزال اخر ايضا حقائق اضيفت الى تحليلات
تهويليه وتنبؤات بان هذه لذات هي تمهيد
لزلزال اكبر
واقوى لكن بدايه ما هي الهزات الارتداديه
وهل فعلا هناك زلزال اخر متوقع وهو اكثر
تدميرا وفق خبراء جيولوجيين الهزات
الارتداديه هي طبيعيه جدا بعد زلزال كبير
كالذي ضرب في السادس من فبراير فكلما كانت
الهزه الاساسيه قويه كلما تبعتها هازات
ارتداديه اكثر على مدن اطول ويمتد احيانا
لايام واسابيع وحتى الى اشهر عند زلزال
قوي مشاهدينا يتحرك قسم كبير من الفالق
الزلزالي المسبب ولكن ليس بالكامل
وبالتالي القسم الذي لم يتحرك سيواصل
تحركه بعد الزلزال لحين عوده الارض الى
طبيعتها وهو ما يسبب هذه الهزات
الارتداديه ايضا يلعب حجم الزلزال وايضا
ضخامته دورا بذلك فطول الكسر الذي تسبب به
زلزال تركيا في الارض يتراوح بين 300 الى
350 كيلومترا ما يستوجب وقتا اطول ليلتئم
الفالق كله
ويؤكد خبراء ان بعض الهزات لم تكن
ارتداديه بل هزات مستقله حدثت على فوالق
اخرى نتيجه الضغط تسبب به زلزال الكبير
على ما يحيط به من فوالق اما التحذير من
امكانيه وقوع زلزال اقوى
فاحتماليته ضعيفه وفق علماء بحكم عد
الفوالق ولا سيما ان زلزال قوي الذي ضرب
قبل اسبوعين حرر القسم الاكبر من الطاقه
الضاغطه فيما القسم الاخر ينتقل من مكان
الى اخر ويحدث هذه الاهتزازات
[موسيقى]